but first the NHS has already become a
key battleground in this election with
both Boris Johnson and Jeremy Corbyn
claiming their party is the only one
that can be trusted with the NHS well
today the Conservatives are promising to
try and relieve the pressure on GP
surgeries with 6,000 more doctors over
the next five years and joining us now
is the health secretary to explain the
policy thank you for being on safe
original sighs good morning how are you
not too bad thank you and so just to
explain to our viewers exactly what it
is that you're announcing today well we
understand the pressure that the primary
care is under and how frustrating it is
if you can't get an appointment of the
doctors and also for the doctors the
pressures are great and we want to
relieve those so over the next five
years we're going to have 6,000 more
doctors in primary care in GP surgeries
and we're going to do that by a
combination of training more so we're
going to increase the annual training
places by 500 we've already got record
numbers of GPS in training but we're
going to increase that we're also going
to do more to help experience GPS to
stay in general practice - many are
retiring early at the moment and that
needs to be tackled and then using the
new NHS visa that we announced yesterday
we're also going to hire more from
abroad it's all about delivering more
appointments so that we can take the
pressure off GPS and make sure that that
that when people need to see their GP
they can get that access as quick as
necessary I mean it's interesting that
at the moment almost half of
appointments that the GP are on the day
so you know the day that you that you
that you need one but clearly there is
that pressure I've seen it for myself I
understand how frustrating it is and I'm
absolutely delighted that we're able to
commit to this package for tackling it
the problem is it does feel a little bit
like this is something that we've heard
all before because in 2016 the
government promised that there would be
5,000 new GPS by 2020 and bluntly that
hasn't happened the number of GPS is
going down know the number of GPS is now
rising
and I'm glad about that but it's not
rising fast enough they'd fallen by a
thousand since 2015
according to reports early this year
well when I took over it's true they
were falling and I'm absolutely
determined to put more support into
primary care and now they're rising but
they need to go more so I'm then glad
that with the very strong support of
Boris Johnson who is emphatic about this
agenda I've we were able to make this
commitment the thing is that over a
generation within the NHS budget a
higher proportion has gone to hospitals
more and more and I think that in order
to stay healthy to have a healthy
population you've got to support people
to stay healthy in the first place you
know prevention is better than cure and
GPS are the bedrock of that they're
absolutely at the heart of helping
people to stay healthy in the first
place so one of the big changes that I'm
trying to make in the NHS as health
secretary is to focus more on prevention
and keeping people healthy and
increasing for the first time in a
generation the proportion of the money
we spend on the NHS that's going into
primary care and today's announcement
just reinforces that direction travel so
yes I fully acknowledge the pressures
and I fully acknowledge that while we've
made progress since 2010 there's a lot
more that needs to be done and today
I've got the the commitment of the money
from the Treasury it's all taxpayers
money so we need to spend it carefully
and we've got the the plan to deliver
the extra GPS and the extra support
staff as well as the extra technology
that's needed to make sure that we take
that pressure off GPS and so that all of
your viewers when they're needed GP
appointment will be able to get one I
understand that you want to talk about
the future of the NHS but many of our
viewers will be very concerned about the
state the NHS is in right now and
clearly the Conservative government have
been in power now for nine years so this
is your record that we're talking about
and people will judge you on your record
rather than your promises so let's just
have a little look how in take stock and
what's happening in the health service
because flu vaccination sessions have
been cancelled in schools because of
shortages 4.4 million people waiting for
a
operation if you look at Amy the key
target of course is that 95% of people
seen within four hours that's a target
that the NHS has not met for more than
five years I mean this is partly on your
watch as health secretary it's certainly
on the watch of the Conservative Party
being in government is this really a
record to be proud of well I think our
record is something that we can be proud
of and the NHS is such a big
organization that you can always find
things that are that are difficult and
challenging I'd totally accept that but
if you look at operation well exactly so
these are fundamental things so you're
experiencing now in the NHS that's right
so I was going to go through the the
points that you made because each one of
them actually is is you know taking the
the worst look at her as a problem so in
terms of the number of people getting
operations there's a record number of
people getting operations there are
million millions more operations done
than the were ten years ago but our
population is getting older by the way
that is a good thing but it does mean
that we need to we need to have more
operations same on cancer or cancer
survival rates are the best they have
ever been we've been one of the fastest
improvers in Europe in terms of cancer
survival rates there are people waiting
now for that cancer diagnosis and and
one of the reasons that we need to put
more resources in there and we are is
because more people are coming forward
because they're being spotted earlier
which makes them more likely to survive
so that is actually a good thing
likewise you mentioned vaccinations and
the rate of vaccination this winter for
the flu is ahead of schedule much higher
than last year especially amongst those
crucial over 65s there's the operational
issue that you mentioned but school
children will get their vaccinations we
just had to move some of the timings
because of a problem with the factories
producing the vaccines but these sorts
of things happen in very large
organisations so the NHS is doing more
than ever before it's more productive
than ever before it's got more funding
than ever before they're an and I am
completely straightforward where there
are problems like the pressures on GP
services
we will fix them okay now currently and
7.3 percent of NHS spending goes on
private providers no no no 7.3 percent
of NHS funding goes on private providers
in 2018-19
no it's no that doesn't include GP
surgeries deep most GPS are private
providers it doesn't include pharmacists
pharmacies of private businesses you
know the NHS has always provided the
services through a mixed economy what
matters is that it is free at the point
of delivery so I'm against the idea that
we would scrap that and against the
privatization of the NHS the idea that
people should have to pay to just to go
for it of course you know the NHS is
always you know the whole drugs budget
in the NHS when you roll out the
percentage of spending on private
providers going up and under their
conservative government well it depends
what you mean I mean I've just committed
to 6,000 more GPS and most GPS are
private companies that are contracted
into the NHS so I certainly wouldn't
want to rule out the number increase in
the number of GPS no likewise the you
know the drugs budget we buy drugs from
pharmaceutical companies their companies
you know the NHS has always bought
things from from private businesses some
things it directly provides and of
course you know we employ 1.4 million
people but other things the NHS buys
from buys from companies or from
partnerships which is private
partnerships which is what most GP
surgeries are or we provide drugs
through pharmacies and pharmacies of
private businesses so you know the NHS
what matters in the NHS to patients is
are we going to get the treatment that
we need at the time we need it free at
the point of delivery according to need
not ability to pay and emphatically yes
we will and we're putting in the
taxpayers money to allow that to happen
and I will spend that taxpayers money as
carefully and as well as I possibly can
now while we've got you I want to ask
you about a really important story that
we've been covering a lot on
Sky News and it's about a girl with
autism and her name is Bethany that's
the only information that we can give
about her but she was sectioned three
years ago because she was deemed a risk
to herself and others at the age of does
15 she's done nothing wrong of course
and I just want to play a short video of
her father talking about the conditions
that she is currently living in because
he can explain this much better than I
can so if we just have a little listen
now to Bethany's father
Beth is locked away it is a cell there's
no furniture in that room there is a
four inch thick mattress on the floor
that she sleeps on there's there's not a
window that she can see out of when it
comes to feeding Beth Beth has to move
to the end of the room sit on the floor
behind a line only then will they open
the door slide her food in and then
quickly lock the door again the video is
of me having my weekly two-hour contact
with Beth to have to kneel down and talk
to your child like that not because
she's a criminal but because she's
autistic and unsupported is is also
being horrific I mean it's it's pretty
heartbreaking to hear from it is yeah
Jeremy there Bethany's father and you
know the NHS England has accepted it's
got her care all the Care Quality
Commission said have made the systems
not fit for purpose the unit where she's
in has acknowledged that they don't have
the expertise to really look after her
yeah I mean she's not a criminal what is
going on and can you give any assurances
to Bethany's father that she's gonna be
moved into somewhere much more suitable
for her name's yes I've met Jeremy and I
I insisted on a serious incident review
a serious case review into Bethany's
care which I've received a couple of
weeks ago and in fact we've published
the executive summary of which is very
unusual because these things are highly
sensitive and and Bethany's case is
incredibly difficult and complex and
there's ten recommendations in that
review which we are considering very
carefully essentially looking at how we
can
take those forward Bethany is in a it
does need to be moved and we're lining
up where we can move her to we've got to
get that right it's a very challenging
situation because her care needs are
very very significant and I would love
to see Bethany be able to move into a
community setting but again that move
would have to have all of the support in
place it's one of the things that you do
as health secretaries you come across
some absolutely heart-rending cases like
this either where the the problems of
the condition are very serious all where
care has gone wrong as it has in this
case and you know you do everything you
can to solve it so as I say I had that
review done it done there there are 10
10 recommendations which we are which
we're working on now I mean in the
departments working on them even whilst
the elections going on but there's a
broader point too which is that there
are just over two thousand people in in
inpatient settings who have severe
learning difficulties and autism
that number is reducing but it could
come down further and I've insisted on a
case review of every single person in
those conditions because the thing I
just want to bring it back to Bethany
can you promise that she will be moved
into somewhere more suitable for
Christmas and will you take this apology
this opportunity to apologize to her
father for the situation that his
daughter has found or something yes of
course I apologized to Jeremy and
frankly to Bethany for the things that
have gone wrong in her care and I the
the current plan is to for her to be
moved to a more appropriate setting
before Christmas I very much hope that
will happen of course that requires a
space to become available and there are
some other there are some other have
people with also very very serious
conditions that and complex cases that
that's currently in the setting that we
that the NHS thinks is most appropriate
for Bethany and so
you know the thing about the thing is
that the Oh Bethany has a an articulate
courageous father who's willing to bring
her attention to her case I'm really
glad that he has even though it's
difficult to you know it's difficult
viewing I'm really glad that he has
because it has helped me to drive the
system to improve the care for people in
those circumstances but there are also
people in similar situations who don't
have that amazing support of their of a
parent and we've got to make sure that
they get the best care as well hence
hence insisting on an independent review
of every single case so that we can
ensure everybody gets the best possible
care I think this is something that we
need to absolutely sort out thank you
and for those as well
just a couple more things and quickly to
ask you all while we have you on and
sorry devarsi the former chair of the
Conservative Party has tweeted to say
that she's disappointed after Boris
Johnson confirmed there will not be an
investigation into Islamophobia in the
Conservative Party now this morning you
said that others take a more balanced
approach to Islam of favor in the
concept of party then so devar say what
exactly did you mean by that what we
need to be absolutely and entirely
tackling Islamophobia and any other kind
of bias or and racism wherever we find
balanced approach well I think it's
incredibly important that you that we
look at the actions that we have taken
we are having the unbalanced approach no
I didn't I don't think that she does I
think that you've got to look at the
whole thing in the round and and you
know as somebody who has tried to tackle
racism and bias wherever I've found it
for instance you know just in the last
week within the NHS we've had we've seen
problems come to light of racism against
NHS staff and I've taken the what I
thought a party here at me absolutely
but at the point I'm trying to make is
that we've got
tackle these problems wherever we find
them including in the Conservative Party
absolutely and we will and we've seen
what happens frankly if you don't tackle
these things in the labour party with
its deep rooted anti-semitism okay we
must do this in the Conservative Party
I'm confident that we will I saw what
the prime minister said and I think
that's the right way to go about it just
finally well we've got you very quickly
when Michael Gove was on the show last
time he said that you and him had had a
bet about whether or not Boris Johnson's
deal was going to get through Parliament
by October 31st and that the prize was a
very nice bottle of wine
so who's ended up with a bottle of wine
then we let us in on the secret
he hasn't given it me yet but it's
coming to me the the question was
whether we'd win the vote on the
principle of the deal by exactly three
and I thought that it would be more than
that the sad thing is that although we
won that vote by 30 and so I'm getting
the bottle of wine we immediately lost
the next vote on whether to actually put
that into practice and so you know
Parliament has still continued to block
brexit and that's why we're having this
general election and I hope we can have
a conservative majority and then we can
get on to all the other things like
sorting out the NHS that we're not
talking about these election messages
even into a question about a bet on a
bottle of wine Matthew Hancock thank you
very much being on the program
this